and i told you these fans uh you know
whether you whether you want to move on
or not near the astros the visiting
folks that made their way here tonight
are not wanting to move on they have
hammered the baseball to open the season
the fourth team since 1900 to score
eight or more runs
in its first four games the five mark
it's never been reached the astro
hitters trying to silence the angel fans
here back to back hips and that'll bring
up alex bregman
bregman's hitting 500 6 for 12. two
homers five runs batted in bregman hooks
one towards left one comes up then it's
gonna get past them as he tried to make
the shoestring catch altuve will be
waived home and the relay throw will not
be made astros take the quick
one-nothing lead on the
line drive single by alex bregman
tough read for the guys on base cause
that ball was hit hard by alex bregman
out there to left field justin upton
didn't get the best of jumps coming in
to get that ball here's correa with one
out runners at first and third that's a
ground ball hit through the left side of
base hit that'll score another as guriel
trots home down to second goes alvarez
and it's two-nothing astros boy just
left another one up with two strikes
that was thigh high for correa the belt
he picks up his first rbi of the season
the astros take the early lead
116.4 miles an hour off the bat
that is a rocket 116.4
wow yeah now it's let me diaz getting to
start in left field tonight
that one gets away on the strikeout here
comes a run to score alvarez scores the
run
oledmiss is going to reach on a ball
that eludes kurt suzuki on a swinging
strikeout astros lead three to nothing
two outs runner on first for walsh
there's the pitch and that's a ball
ripped on the first base side and
stopping that one right near the bag
guriel he just reached the glove down
kind of olayed that one and it stayed in
the glove that was a very good play if
that ball gets by him that's down in the
corner still runners on first and second
there's one out now for altuve and it's
poked to right field and that's a base
hit
around third is straw they're gonna test
fowler here's the play at the plate safe
the astros lead four to nothing on the
rbi single by altuve that is gonna be
the last batter that quintana will face
with yuli guriel do up talented young
right-hander chris rodriguez trots in
lauren hill wyclef jump prize the fuji's
that's i mean that's me i mean i i live
that era but killing me softly that's
that's your walkouts out so i mean
you're a fuji's guy oh yeah oh yeah it
was funny uh my girlfriend uh she was
actually the one who uh
gave me the idea and i was listening to
it i was i put it on instagram for a
bunch of recommendations and all of a
sudden i heard this i heard the fuji
song and i was just like dun dun dun dun
dun and i just i just bobbing my head i
said this is great and i was ready to go
so the bases are now loaded boy
don't want this game to get out of hand
right here that's great
outside
[Applause]
still have to contend with jordan though
he swings to that one lifts it in the
air but it's right near up then he has
to come in a couple feet he's under
he'll make the catch and that is how the
inning will end so rodriguez comes in
slams the door shut angel's only a
couple of base runners in this game
couple of walks by
garcia is it so here's the pitch on mike
trout high fly ball
deep left field oh 27.
does it again
mike trout's first home run of the
season and it was a towering drive right
down that left field line angels get on
the scoreboard
first hit given up tonight by garcia
it's now 4-1 astros the angels have
runners at first and second iglesias
ready to bat off the end of the bat
dumps it into left-center field for a
base and rendon easily hurries on a
round there's another run back
four to two mark that to what you were
calling for not trying to be a hero do
too much just turn the turn style let's
keep everyone going and just keep that
pressure on
so really issues the walk the angels
have the tying runs on with one out for
upton a little pop into shallow left
field coming in hard unable to get to it
as diaz that's going to drop in that's
going to score a run as walsh will come
in from second on the loop hit off the
bat of upton an rbi single his second
hit of the night and now the angels
trail it by just a run 4-3 talented
right-hander chris rodriguez gets ready
to continue to eat some time in this
ball game
that's not even close to the strike zone
never really
near the strike zone for the late break
the spin on that breaking ball well you
love it when jordan gets to the plate
with runners on and jordan lines it over
the head of fletcher in the shift and
then the right field racing around third
and coming home is maldonado the photo
to play the slide aldonado is saved
suzuki couldn't handle the ball cleanly
and maldonado able to get the hand in
there in the astros lead five to three
alvarez drives in a run
on the field guessing that's an
inflatable trash can that has been
shared on the field
kind of creative
you just don't want things on the field
what will they think of next jose altuve
will be the batter and the fans have
booed him
all night long so earlier we had an
inflatable trash can this time it's an
actual trash can on the warning track
and right center field steve goes back
to work with an o2 count
not a swing on a slider that never was a
strike the entire time angels have
runners at first and second back-to-back
hits off of joe smith shohei ohtani will
be
coming in as the
inch hitter for the catcher kurt suzuki
and that one comes in and he's hit by
the pitch took a long look out to smith
i mean a long look and a long look for
maldonado at show hey you know what he
hit him it's never fun to be hit with a
baseball so the angels now
have him loaded with nobody out dexter
fowler base it left field
they're going to stop iglesias it's a
5-4 game fowler gets it done david
fletcher will bat with the bases loaded
and nobody out rolled right side
they get fouler that's all they will get
that's all they will get and we're tied
while she's the hero last night chance
to do it again tonight
bouncing ball diving stop they're coming
home but they saving the play
[Applause]
advantage and tucker hits it in the air
deep to center going back on it is trout
looking up see you later
kyle tucker homers
his second of the year
and the astros
get back to within a run and one more
out to go
high pop up left side
stacey over in front of his dugout hey
got it
the comeback kids do it again
one of baseball's best stories is being
written by the beach the angels
off to a 4-1 start wow